[ YouTube Learning ]
Alright, you’ve now uploaded your first
video to your YouTube channel and you’d be
very excited to see how your video is doing!
You should know that for your video to do well,
you should ENGAGE with your audience.
And how can you do that?
Let’s see!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
The first thing you should do after you upload
your video is share it with as many people as possible.
How do we do that?
An easy way is to go to YouTube Studio by clicking here,
and then going to the Videos section.
You will see your list of videos here.
Click on the 3 dots next to whichever video
you wish to share and then click on “Get Sharable Link”.
This link is now copied, and you can paste
it wherever to share it with your students.
You should share your videos on
as many platforms as possible:
Google Classroom
social media pages, your email channels, and so on!
The more you share your videos,
the higher your chances of outreach.
After you share your video,
you will also start getting comments on it,
and it’s important
that you reply to as many comments as you can.
You can access the comments section by going to
YouTube Studio, and then clicking on Comments here.
By default, you will be able to see the list
of comments, you haven’t responded to.
Remember that if your video is made for kids,
then comments will be turned off for your video
by default.
Now you could reply to a comment, or give
the comment a heart to show your love!
When you do that, the person who commented gets a
notification and that increases engagement on
your channel.
Let’s switch back to the channel view now!
Another great way to interact with your subscribers
is by going LIVE.
Remember that in order to go live,
you will first need to go to the channel settings.
Then we can click on
‘Channel Status and Features’,
and verify your channel by entering your phone number.
There you go, your account is now verified.
There’s one more step we need to do!
We need to go back to the channel settings, Click on
‘Channel Status and Features’ again,
and then enable live streaming.
You should get this message on your screen.
After 24 hours, you will be able to go live
using your webcam.
Now let me use another account to show you the steps
you need to follow to go live!
Click on this button in the top right area,
and then click on ‘Go Live’.
It will get you to this screen.
Write a good title that your audience will
relate to, click on unlisted, and schedule
it if you wish to go live at a later date.
Once you click on Next, you will then be asked to smile
for a thumbnail and it will get you to this screen.
You can also retake the thumbnail if you wish to.
You can then click on Share, and copy the
link you see here.
You can now share this link with all your
subscribers or students
and tell them that you will be going live soon.
This is crucial because your fans or subscribers will be
prepared for your live session in advance.
They will not only clear their calendar for
your session, but will also keep important questions
ready for you!
Clicking on Done will show you that your live stream link
is saved, and you can always change
the date or the thumbnail here by clicking
on this link!
If you wish to schedule another live stream,
you could click here and do it.
And YouTube has made it really safe for creators
to chat with their viewers during the live stream.
You or a moderator you select can easily moderate
the comments.
So if any viewer is posting misleading or
inappropriate comments,
then the comment can easily
be removed and the viewer can be blocked as well.
A couple of interesting things about Live Streaming:
As we just saw, the Live Streaming through
webcam is activated only after 24 hours.
And live streaming through mobile phone will be
possible only if you have more than
one thousand subscribers on your channel.
There are a couple of more ways
to engage with your audience.
When you upload a prerecorded video,
you have a choice to choose the Premiere option.
This means when your video is launched,
you can watch it with your subscribers and chat
with them using the chat feature.
Once you have enough subscribers, you can also use
your Community Tab and the Stories
feature to share pictures and videos
with your fans.
The Community Tab is an engagement tool
you can use to get closer to your subscribers
by sharing images, or GIFs, or even polls for that matter.
And your subscribers will even get notifications
for your posts.
YouTube stories, on the other hand, are short,
mobile-only videos that you can share with
your subscribers on the go.
Each story can have a maximum length of 15 seconds,
and will last only for 7 days and then disappear.
It’s a nice way for your subscribers
to know you better.
Note that engaging with your audience is very important
for your YouTube channel to grow.
So keep working hard,
upload good content consistently,
and you will win!
Good luck!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]